hey leute uci teure mal wandern
willkommen zu einem neuen test test
video heute wieder mit fast folien
lieben fastfood
mcdonald's subway nordsee domino's pizza
aber was macht man wenn man mitten in
seiner diät steckt sich gesünder
ernähren bestimmt man ist zum beispiel
mit freunden unterwegs oder man stellt
mit freunden und alle möchten eine pizza
bestellen kann man sich eine gesunde
alternative bestellen das finden wir
heute heraus ich hab nämlich bei vielen
fast-food-ketten bestellt und die
bestellungen sind jetzt alle da außer
einer lässt auf sich warten subway wo
bist du
unser letzter kandidat ist dort auch ins
herz letztes da war ich habe einen
gleich viel trinke gegeben denn trinke
lebenswichtig na ja schön dass von all
dem essen nichts fertiges dabei ist es
jetzt in der reihenfolge in der es
geliefert wurde eine sache möchte ich
heute auch herausfinden ob das nur die
billige healthy alternative oder ob
vielleicht die gesunden alternativen so
lecker sind es sich in zukunft bei
dominus mir immer ein salat bestellen
werden hinaus
als erstes ist dominus angekommen - ist
bekannt für seine pitts neuerdings
machen sie auch sehr gute vegane pizzen
also ich habe ja schon mal veganes
fastfood getestet und dido - egal ob
pizza war wirklich sehr gut dominus hat
25 minuten für die lieferung gebraucht
ich habe einen rap für fünf euro 99 und
einen salat für acht euro 99 insgesamt
14 98 mal für ein mittagessen ein salat
899 doch ich würde es an den preis jetzt
noch nicht sagen ich glaube die preise
sind alle relativ ähnlichen bei pharmexx
gucken wir uns mal den salat an so
stellt man sich ein sonder vor also auf
den ersten blick richtig gut das ist der
salat ich sehe hier frische
frühlingszwiebeln tomaten werden kann
man im salat falsch machen aber es sieht
alles sehr knackig und frisch aus und
wir haben natürlich noch sehenswert
praktisch lieben wir ja optisch sieht es
erst mal aus wien treibt das ist
natürlich auch gucken wir drin aussieht
dafür bräuchten stehen
brauchen wir dich schneit den web
einfach mal in der mitte durch noch nie
was gesundes bei einem fast food laden
bestellt fällt mir gerade a klar da
macht man ja noch france reise das ist
der griechische style also das sieht
sehr frisch aus in der mitte
womit fange ich an tragen das war mit
dem song ich habe jetzt beide - zwei mal
griechischer art genommen weil es keine
fleisch- alternativen gab und ich habe
mit hühnchen bestellt aber ich wollte es
nicht überall mit hinnehmen stellen
wollen habe ich hier zum salat mit
münchen das wollte ich auch nicht machen
ja es gab leider keinen liegen schnitzel
kichererbsen irgend waren die nährwerte
hochzutreiben das heißt das einzige wo
wir so ein bisschen protein es unseren
sport kriegen ist halt wie käse gibt
damals ein bisschen was drauf viele
zwiebeln
bon appétit baby
geht voll durch
die zwiebeln hätte ein bisschen kleiner
sein können die vierte gekostet
wasser für kriegen ja nicht gesagt das
ist ein sehr guter salat er ist frisch
schmeckt so wie er schmecken soll und
ich bin positiv überrascht ich werde
zwei tage nicht kochen müssen wir mal
zum rap der wolf ist eigentlich das
gleiche wie das brot hat halb croutons
noch mit drin und lisa dressing
[Musik]
also das mit raps auf sich warum
schmeckt etwas brot natürlich
als rap schmeckt dieser salat
hoch wie keiner
werde keine punkte geben weil am ende
des tages ist ein bisschen salat in dem
brief
domino's du hast mich absolut nicht
enttäuscht sehr sehr gut ich bin
wirklich sehr positiv überrascht mit
einer lieferzeit von 50 minuten
die beueler ich habe kein fisch bestellt
weil alles so gebacken und frittiert war
aber ich war doch sehr überrascht vom
alternativen angebot von dort sehen
gemüse sind klein gemüse reis
kartoffeln und natürlich gut dabei
langsam
irgendwas richtig nicht gut
und man kennt es für so einen kleinen
salat brauchen natürlich 100 milliliter
dahin kommen wir zum aussehen das
aussehen sieht so aus wie es aussieht
sollte also ja ich finde die seen bis
jetzt hält aus aber ich glaube
kartoffeln sehen so aus wenn sie lange
warm gemacht werden diese kartoffel
sieht aus als ob sie auf den boden
gefallen wäre ich weiß nicht wie viertel
frei essen sein sollten aber diese
kartoffel hat sehr viele fussel aufsicht
auf
einer kartoffel
die es sich nicht leicht schlechter aus
als alle andern hast du gerade fusseln
drauf ja wir probieren mal den namen
davon vergessen denn ist so eine
mischung aus blumenkohl und brokkoli
oder
da man weiß dass das von nordsee ist
habe ich das gefühl es hat alles im
fisch geschmack
ein nordsee hat alles 250 gekostet bei
nordsee um alle bei lang 250 kosten dann
habe ich mir noch wasser dazu gestellt
also bin ich bei 50h 250 dafür
dass ist
schmeckt immer wieder diesen fisch
dadurch kann doch nicht sein ich bin ja
ein großer fan von gemüse reis deswegen
bin ich sehr gespannt wie dieser hier
schmeckt diese reis gibt mir einfach
flashbacks zu meiner kindheit
also man kann essen ich habe aus der
hungers hat aber keinen geschmack
denn die mitte rey hat nicht so wirklich
viel geschmack
ich möchte nicht nach fisch
branche von
nordheim sorry aber du bist sowas von
durchgefallen jetzt kann ich nur noch
ein wunderbarer salat retten der joghurt
dressing cremig vollmundig und mit
kräutern abgestimmt keine ahnung warum
gerade der salat in der
plastikverpackung kommen muss
fachgerecht gene vorbereite und eine
laktose tabletten hab ich schon genommen
und gewinn
sind noch kleine streifen radieschen
rote beete höhere drin war ja sehr viel
falsch machen aber es ist jetzt auch
nicht besonders gute tage so umfang war
auf das war so nicht geplant aber mein
video sieht von der farbigkeit genauso
aus wie das wetter gerade draußen
ansichtig grau und trist oder ich habe
das gefühl ich schaue gerade aufs
display und seine beerdigung die
beerdigung von los
wir machen weil sonst zu den nährwerten
von nordsee kann ich sagen ja da ist
halt fisch der ja grundsätzlich gesund
ist dann wird halt auch alles probiert
was ich früher immer ganz geil fand war
bei nordsee die fischbrötchen aber
dieses fischbrötchen war es war so
gebackener fisch und das war nicht gut
das ich glaube nord sie haben extrem
abgebaut ihr könnt ihr mal gerne
schreiben falls ihr gerne zur nordsee
gehen was hat die vegan alternativen
angeht ja sie haben jetzt dieses fisch
mit v also zwischen chips ist aber dass
deshalb frittiert also es wäre nett
gewesen wenn die gesunden alternativen
jetzt richtig gut geschmeckt hätten aber
tun sie nicht mit einer lieferzeit von
einer stunde und acht minuten
mcdonald's mccafé zu bekommen aber das
liegt daran dass meine bestellung hat so
klein ich habe mir bei mcdonald's den
pixar chicken salad beginnen und den mac
app mit schicken sie seien
als gesunde alternative bietet
mcdonald's wirklich kein vegetarisch
vegan an dass man das ja also gibt es
nicht außerdem bei langen salat aber gut
was soll ich da bewerten kann ich ein
bisschen schade ich meine sie können ja
auch so wie burger king jetzt einfach
soja protein oder in welche
ersatzprodukte nehmen und die ja auch in
den salat reinmachen ich es ab und zu
machen aber das ist wirklich
mittlerweile so selten geworden stehe
halt wirklich auf kicker erbsen
schafskäse als solches protein nämlich
gern
macdonald also leute jetzt über
wahnsinn das ist ja aufwand das ist eine
leistung die ihr gerade erbracht wird es
ist so komisch mcdonald's in der hand zu
haben aber nicht mcdonald's in der hand
zu haben bis sie was ich meine da kommt
keine pommes 490 der salat da war ich
wirklich überraschungen
539 der welt aber der ist hier auch
kleiner als der von
dings noch nicht alles
okay
[Gelächter]
anzeigen sowie deren bürger aussehen
wird auch dieser salat aus unfassbar das
ist ok ich hab' ich wusste ich dachte
daran hähnchen streifen und ich dachte
hähnchen streifen heißt halt irgendwie
gegrilltes hähnchen oder so nein wir
haben chicken mcnuggets u
ok ich doch nicht packt seine rap auf
den grills onagawa dominus sap einfach
gut die streifen sehen vielleicht ganz
nett aus war ja auch günstiger das wird
sich so falsch und ja aussehen er - naja
es ist aber so typisch ist es zu dieser
mitteilung oder sind das hat mich hier
fertig gemacht ist das wirklich dann
anna die am unteren salat mix dieser
salat als wie burger aber einfach nicht
im brötchen und ein bisschen messala ich
hätte es nicht erwartet aber ich glaube
selbst beim salat und beim raps sind die
nährwerte von mcdonald's wieder relativ
weit unten ja und das böse mit gutem
essen ist auch sehr sehr belastet wenn
ich hier schon chicken mcnuggets hat
dann sollte ich wenigstens eine süßsaure
soße haben
müssen wie hässlich kann ein salat
angelegt seien
gut aber ich mein wenn manchmal bei
mcdonald ist und will man ja auch den
mac dann ist geschmack
also von den mehrwerten fällt der hier
auf jeden fall durch ich meine es ist
ein kreatives schicken da so ein
bisschen protein ist aber auch wieder
eine panade die also frittierte panade
drumrum du hast drei scheiben tomaten
und leitwerk salatbars nichts dran und
ein haufen voller kartons allem egal
schafft auch dass die kohlenhydrate über
wie auch im salat
so jetzt hab ich immer eine hoffnung
gegen web gestellt
erinnert euch nicht gleichzeitig daneben
aber versucht euch mal daran zu erinnern
wie frisch der domino sap aussagen jetzt
der mcdonald's das ist ja nur brot und
tun da sind drei scheiben salat drin
eine gesunde alternative bei mcdonald's
der rap muss ein scherz sein von
mcdonald's die bürger sind ja auch
teilweise entschärft
wenn der vielleicht noch mit sondern
veganen peggy wäre das sich nicht ganz
so freudig anfühlen aber das hühnchen
hat so komischen opel drin der geschmack
ist wirklich auch nicht ja es nicht gut
war war das gefühl mcdonalds möchte gar
nicht dass man diese gesunden
alternativen kaufen bei burger pommes
bleibt wollen bevor ihr wieder wind
unter die tastatur schreibt ja ich weiss
macdonald ist im fast food geschäft
trotzdem keiner sagen mit einer
lieferzeit von eine stunde und 16
minuten haben wir kaum pizza pizza und
dominus hatte ich eigentlich und
lieferzeit aufs gleiche level gesetz
weil das ja beides so hauptsächlich
lieferanten sind da wird es deshalb aber
trotzdem was haben wir denn bestellt bei
call a pizza
naja ich hab mein kolle pizza am salat
bestellt
auch wieder anders endet weil ich das
mit dem ceasar salad von mcdonald's
vergleichen wollte und ich dachte mal
eine gesunde alternative haben ja auch
nudeln seien in diesem fall vollkorn
kenne mit broccoli toskana sauce und
cherrytomaten die sie vielleicht rein
gemacht haben das finden wir noch heraus
sie waren hier dann bei ungefähr 20 euro
insgesamt jahre alt und das hat nicht so
wirklich noch weiter vorne
schwimmen
ich habe nichts mehr gestellt wir sind
sie dass teile des spezialisten deswegen
gibt das ist als erstes diese großen
stücken
wunderschön mit soße mit dem schmeckt
dann ist kein richtiger salat das ist so
nicht haben salat bestellt ja
also käse und hühnchenfleisch
und das ist sehr wichtig
das ende - 1 große zwiebel stücke aber
diese zwei stücke die hip-hopper
wenigsten das ist hier eine ganz schön
fett triebel kiloweise tiere ja
ich habe mich hier wirklich vergriffen
das ist hast du keine gesunde
alternative dieser salat hat auch am
ende 900 1000 kalorien kann sehr
übertrieben aber ich glaube tatsächlich
dass er so um die 900 kalorien wir
werden unsere nudeln umso besser
vollkornnudeln mit brokkoli was kann man
da hin falsch machen
wie man diese weise sagen will brauchen
die kann ich essen der aktion
verschieden geschmack meiner nudeln
tropfen
das ist sowieso schwimmen diese nudeln
in einem ölbad die cherrytomaten sie
auch vergessen
das ist so schlecht ich wusste nicht
dass man nun so schlecht zubereiten kann
[Musik]
also ich meine du kochst nudeln pasta
sauce drauf und dann will die person
noch extra broccoli also schweizerin mal
brocken wie schwer kann das sein warum
schwimmt diese nudeln in öl die
versteh's nicht es tut mir so leid für
das essen ist das wieder nicht gewesen
keine empfehlung und das geht hier nicht
jetzt so unberührt das ist mir zu viele
kalorien nein es ist wirklich absolut
ruhig gewesen also gesehen öle sind auch
im fett ist in ordnung besonders frauen
brauchen fed in ihrer ernährung mehr als
männer weil wir einfach frauen sind toll
sind mir richtig schlecht weil
es als einziges noch nicht in 2022
angekommen und packen es in eine
plastiktüte mit einer lieferzeit von ich
habe nicht mal mehr auf geschrieben weil
es ganz schön lange war also ich glaube
fast zwei stunden die tüte ist von im
nass mit dem bon
ich finde es
liefert es so wie man sich das gedacht
hat dass hapoel das liefert der salat
wow wow wow also ja doch es ist tabu die
zulagen sind bestimmt frisch aber diese
anordnung das macht mich fertig und
jetzt denkt ihr vielleicht ich habe noch
ein halbes abbestellt nein ja auch da
habe ich einen rap weinreb in meiner
logik weniger brot ist und deshalb ein
bisschen
gesünderen kann aber schon hier habe ich
generell sagen dass hatte immer die
bessere alternative ist wenn man
unterwegs schnelles fastfood möchte wie
brot lass dich dieser brief ist einmal
den rapidler aufschneiden das ist zufall
dass sich wieder so ordentlich angelegt
aus so richtig die leute haben gelernt
wie man das macht also und das ist ein
spinat wintergrün vegane alternativen ja
sie sind da im hirn gemüse die
das sind alles gerichte ich noch nie
bestellt aber von jeder fast-food-kette
hat man das gefühl man schmeckt die fast
food kette
japan bestimmt
[Musik]
der salat kostet 690 und
390 war uns im brot haben willst
günstiger das ist auch schon wieder es
ist einfach dieses veggie salat und wer
die treppe ist diese eine alternative
es ist nicht ungenießbar es ist
rechtlich index für den nährstoffen
haben sie ja noch irgendwo gewonnen weil
sie dieses penny haben und da ist
bestimmt so ein bisschen protein und so
weit drin aber zackig epson oder kippen
den boden oder sollten die schon heimat
ich bin überrascht wie ihr aber dominus
heute ein ganz klarer sieger hätte nicht
gedacht dass keiner an den dom - salat
und ein foto -
replicator diese frische dieses knackige
dieses geschmackvolle gerade so viel
mehr
das schmeckt so viel besser als das
andere zeigt unser sieger des tages
dieses video war auf jeden fall eine
achterbahn der gefühle eine achterbahn
den geschmacksnerven wenn ihr mal in
einer gruppe bestellt und du dazwischen
sitzt und dir denkst ich habe doch
eigentlich gerade meinen diätplan recht
kann jetzt gerade eine pizza essen auch
wenn ich so gern wollte dann sagt der
minister holt ihr euch euren rap oder
euren salat da macht ihr nichts falsch
ich bin baff wie viel besser dominus war
ich dachte er der gewinner mit subway
sein aber es ist toll -
er hat leckeres essen gemacht was nicht
weiß ich hoffe euch hat dieser test es
gefallen und ihr wollt mehr von finden
es wandel sehen wenn dem so ist dann
da kommt doch gerne zum nächsten video
wieder abonniert diesen kanal vergessen
und gibt auch mal wieder einen daumen
nach oben leid dieser daumen nach unten
majors habe ich das gefühl dass man
diese region überhaupt komplett
ignorieren das hilft doch ganz gut
meinen kanal zu unterstützen also nach
oben nicht vergessen wollen wir sehen
uns dann müssen erst einmal die habe ich
schon gesagt schreib mir gerne eure
meinung zu den produkten oder eure
geheimtipp den die kommentare